[Music]
so the first thing I want to talk to you
about is collaborating with Ian because
I know that you're not only the director
but you produced it and you're a
co-screenwriter with Ian and Ian wrote
the book so I wanted to talk about is
there anything that didn't end up on the
screen that was in the book that you
guys probably had a little row about
uh you know I know it's not exciting to
talk about our guest because we actually
really got along oh good and we actually
really
agreed but we're very different um so
the way we worked on the script is he
would do a pass send it to me then I'd
do a pass it was a little bit like that
um and uh we complimented each other in
in lots of ways um but no we we weirdly
we didn't have hardly any arguments in
fact we just spot each other well that's
beautiful to hear I know that's a it's a
rare story but it's true it is rare and
I'm all there for
it um and I also want to talk about the
fact that this feels like in 2023 the
year of AI there are a lot of films that
have been released this year centering
around AI the Creator for 20th Century
Fox there's um this one there's two
films that played at Venice here with
Robert zekis and aggro drift that was
directed by Harmony career
and whenever I see films like this I
always think of a old school film two
old school films Logan's Run
B and Blade Runner Brant right so I
think of those two films and I just
wanted to get your thoughts
on having a film that is kind of like is
centered in a an apocalypse that's
surrounded in the world of AI taking
over our world it takes place in I think
it's
2065 yeah so that's not that far away
from now now it's all coming you can all
have a fake husband or wife whenever you
want one it's definitely coming um I
guess uh it was weird when we when we
I've been working on fa for quite a few
years now so things were coming true as
we're making it so that was kind of
alarming um but there wasn't as many AI
things going on when we started but
anyway I guess what really interested me
was this um IDE aidea of how the science
fiction elements of the story and the AI
elements of the
story gave us this propulsion to explore
this marriage um the idea that hen
could uh have a relationship with a
version of her husband like when she
first met him was a really kind of
really exciting idea to me so yes it we
do tackle the themes of artificial
intelligence but really it's a
relationship story whereby these other
elements really kind of enhance it but
but I guess what it also does to me the
environment and the AI I guess it's
basically making it feel very imminent
in it because it's kind of very close to
us right now and this sense when you
feel a ticking
clock you do reflect on how you're
living your life and I guess that's what
I think these two elements really bring
to the story it's like you know we have
responsibility for the time that we have
here in the lives that we're living um
so anyway and conscious is a pretty cool
thing to explore too yeah it is I want
to talk about did you rehearse the
scenes at all particularly the two
scenes I'm particularly in um thinking
about are the um the one in the living
room where they're they're dancing and
singing and carrying on and she Wallops
him upside the
head you know what I mean the dinner the
dinner table Yeah the dinner table scene
and then um the interrogation or
interview scenes did you rehearse those
with the actors
uh no so no uh no I don't look I don't
normally rehearse the scenes um we did
rehearse the very big scene at the
beginning when Terren arrives that was
like a I hate to think how long it was
eight pages or something um we
definitely rehearsed that because it
was it's probably where the film is at
it's most awkward because there's so
many secret rivers and conceits and lies
and what's really there's a the story
you think you're watching and the story
that's really happening um and to try
and find the calibration of that through
camera and performance definitely
performance was something I really
needed to we needed to feel it and just
get a taste of it um so we did actually
rehearse the actual scene um so that was
uh we like rehearsed it for 4 days wow
just that one scene just to try and find
the flavor of the movie um all the other
things uh I did in rehearsal was about
about um relationships character um in
fact I took all the actors to a to a
forest to rehears to rehearse I just
thought we should be around the living
environment because for a long time we
going to be without a single tree and to
really feel the paos and the emotion of
losing losing the trees so it's things
like that that I do to kind of cement
those deeper elements for the actors I'm
intrigued about this rehearsing in the
forest situation what exactly so walk me
through like maybe one of the days of
rehearsal in the forest what did you
guys focus on mainly did you did you
just give them was it an improv
situation where you gave them some
things to um grasp on to and then they
went from there or was it very
structured uh the days were pretty
structured so we definitely plan the
days um and sometimes it would
be um individual work or pairing um
sometimes it would be tasks where I'm
not involved I'd send them them off to
do something um like getting them to
cook a meal in the kitchen and then
going going finding a tree sitting under
it h hen has a relationship with trees
in the story so she went and had to go
and find some particular trees come back
and talk about their personalities and
things like that I mean there's all
sorts of things that we would do um I
guess for me these are the things that
do something pretty special um to to the
actors and to their connection to the
characters what about terrence's
character was he in the forest too he
didn't like
forests and we're in Australia too so he
didn't like snakes or spiders so he was
quite afraid so he was kind of in
character straight away um look I think
he I think it did have an impact on him
definitely but he was a little out of
his comfort zone for sure yeah I I could
only imagine cuz Australia are known for
those snakes and spiders and it's not
cute someone who's who's been there I
want to talk about
um the scenes with hen in the shower
they were shot twice the one in the
beginning that opens the film and then
the one where we just literally see her
feet in the shower with the dirt being
washed off and I'm just curious to know
if the opening scene is a washing away
of whatever she's holding on to in that
moment that starts the film and is the
second one the dirt and the guilt and
the grime of of knowing that she's going
to be living a different existence
pretty
soon yeah I mean I'm really sorry you've
just watched the movie and it's a bit of
a head fuck so I I know that like it'll
all be it'll all be clear tomorrow um so
I guess um uh when you reflect back on
on it right now when we talk about it um
the opening scene is really is is is the
first night of the experiment so her
real husband has left for space there's
a an artificial intelligence copy of her
husband downstairs on the couch is going
to be turned on in a minute um so this
this night's going to start she has no
understanding of how real it's going to
be so the shower for me um was basically
her kind of feeling that sense of um
fear of agreeing to do this experiment
sense of um the first time being alone
her husband being away and and feeling
that sense of time she's going to be
doing this for and then you'll notice
the this the shots following it's almost
like an an actress preparing for stage
putting on the you know putting on the
layers the armoring so the first shot is
her is how she it's her fear if you know
what I mean can does she have the
courage um so that's that's really the
emotional aspect of that shot but the
plug in the bath is really she saves the
water for her tree um which is symbolic
of
this is how she lives her life and at
the end there is no plug in the bath so
she's you know she's leaving I guess but
yes the the mud is absolutely symbolic
of of washing away the stuff that she's
been holding the reason I asked that is
because when I particularly in my
personal life have had a really rough
day I love to take a shower and just
wash the day off of me right and let it
go down the drain with whatever came in
the house with me and then once it's
down the drain I can move on to a
renewed spirit and A Renewed sense well
yeah it's also um when she was in the
relationship with Junior when he was
there um that was her place that she
could emote you know and and qu you know
privately so there was definitely that
um and um and I guess the piano is the
other place that she could emote in the
music you know like maybe explore those
feelings that she hasn't had the courage
to kind of voice with
him yeah I I want to talk a little
little bit about the the interview scene
and I want to know what was the choice
to have Junior face the wall as opposed
to face Terrence as he was talking to
them to him and all he heard was his
voice and Terren has this eerily calm
like resonant voice so it's the kind of
voice that either can soothe you to
sleep or can get on your last nerve you
know what I mean yeah a couple of
questions there um I guess the the the
posture of the situation was all to do
with the way that he's monitoring his
brain and and and it's also just very
Ian read just
weird um and and kind of to raise a lot
of questions for the audience like
what's really going on here I guess so
definitely to kind of create kind of a
an oddness but it's he's basically being
monitored and then in terms of
terrence's
um his kind of his his ways I guess um
he I mean really what he's trying to do
is he's trying to it feels like almost
like evil provocation half the time like
it's like he's really really pushing him
and provoking him but ultimately what
he's trying to do is is break his
rigidity you know like he knows the real
junior is very he's he's clo he's closed
down he's he's not spontaneous anymore
and I guess he's trying to make the
experiment as exciting as possible he
wants to know can he break it how far
can he push it um so there's all of that
but to do that properly he can't
he it's that mixture of um provocation
and
charm distraction so we had to find the
Rhythm and the tempo of the dialogue and
and a away in his performance so
suddenly it felt real and then it was
charming and it was friendly was that a
joke wasn't it a joke um so you're very
disorientated so yeah um Aaron Pierre
did it beautifully the other thing that
we to try and make it feel very grounded
too as we kind of brought in this kind
of paternal feeling
uh to his performance and I said it's
almost like imagine you've had a son in
a relationship early in your life and
you left that relationship and the son
doesn't know that you exist and you've
come back to live with him you know 20
years later you know that kind of idea
like he's your son but he doesn't know
you're you're the father and and just
little things little notes like that
really brought some some of that kind of
Creator feeling to it that kind of
paternal quality so all of that in there
um in know and gives that
richness thank you for that I I was
really interested to know what that was
about and yes I just want to give some
some props to Aaron Pierre because I did
watch his work before when he was in the
Underground Railroad directed by Barry
Jenkins and he was phenomenal in that
and he's even more grounded and
phenomenal in this I wanted to
know and and the other thing is you know
you usually don't see people of color in
those types of roles in Sci-Fi movies
you don't really see us in Sci-Fi movies
at all so I'm wondering if the character
was written to be a person of color in
the script and in the book or if you
guys just got the best person for the
role and I'm imagining you just got the
best person for the role that's totally
how I work definitely um he also had to
whoever we cast had to feel very
different to the other two like
physically you know um we didn't want
junior to feel like he could just
physically remember moving from the
space so you know Aaron has this
beautiful stature and he has these
beautiful eyes I just for whatever
reason I just wanted someone that was
beautiful you know um to kind of come in
and just these eyes um so yeah I was
just yeah I'd always go for the best the
best soul I guess and um here was this
beautiful man that came across our our
desk and um he he has this incredible
ability to bring Tru truth to everything
he's doing in the character like he
actually believes that this is going to
enhance Humanity you know and um he
found ways to make that feel very
truthful thank you yeah he's fantastic
he's really he really is and so are Paul
and and S shiron and they just the three
of them together work really really well
it it was a great combination of of
acting Talent put together I want to
talk about the sker Davis song and I
want to know the lyrics from it I just
want to read a little bit of it don't
you know it's the end of the world cuz
you don't love me anymore I felt like it
was dealing with the loss of love in
addition to the actual end of the world
the apocalyptic thing that I was
speaking about earlier with you know the
dust storms and the drought and the rain
and all of that and I just want to know
what was your thought process in
selecting the music for the film because
that one when I because you can hear the
lyrics to that song very very clearly
and I just wanted to know what the
thought process with was with the
musical selection yeah I guess um we
really like the idea that um the house
is almost like a haunted house it's like
it's got the ghosts
of you know Junior's family the
generations of his family have been
living in this house and hen is just the
next matriarchal not matriarchal the
next woman in line of the patriarchal um
generational thing and I guess we kept
coming across all this nostalgic music
um and it just feels like all these
women yearning you know in this in this
old music it always felt like people
yearning a loved one or yearning to do
something different or to be somewhere
else so something about the period And I
guess the the the qu that yearning
quality in the music was something that
just felt like it wasn't just hen's
music it was probably all of the Women's
Music before her as well my mother their
mother this mother next mother that kind
of thing um and yeah and then every now
and then we'd stumble across a track
that may have lined up nicely with the
themes of the film as well but you'll
notice that yeah pretty much everything
she listens to is very nostalgic was
were the songs that she played on the
piano were those original compositions
yes yes so very early on I really wanted
to get that composed and find who that
was going to be and it was a this really
beautiful artist called Agnes Obel um
she's Danish born lives in Berlin and um
she had never done a score before um and
sent her the script and she just fell in
love with hen she said I know this woman
I said great and um and then we
um we had a long conversation and I sent
her this really detailed but simple
brief and she I just encouraged her to
not think about doing scores or pieces
of music like just play for each you
know each emotional Arc so she did give
me five minutes 2 minutes 10 minutes um
and she was just channeling hen in in in
those particular moments and uh I didn't
really change anything she just found it
like so precisely it was beautiful the
music was really really beautiful just
to lighten it up a little bit G what was
up with the beetle dude the beetle was
just showing up in closet showing up in
sinks I'm not allowed to talk about the
beetle really Ian ra said do not talk
about the beetle oh no we can talk about
it if you want what was it for you what
was it for me I couldn't figure out if
the beetle was a camera I couldn't
figure out if the beetle was some some
uh throwback futuristic sign of what
they were about to go into like I just
couldn't figure out what it was
representative of but I knew it was
representative of
something um everyone should have their
own interpretation and it's
correct um he's like that's my story and
I'm sticking to it yeah no no it's fine
no but I've I've got my version of it um
and I guess what I found f fascin look
we all had lots of ideas of what it
could be we knew it it we knew it did
something to us when we had it in the
script like it it did something to us
made us feel something so we were
definitely keen on that um and then as
we were making it it it it became
clearer especially to me I mean what was
interesting to me was that both both the
junior Ai and the hen AI I hope you guys
know that there was a replacement at the
end that's close um
they both have this it's very
fascinating the artificial
intelligence see a beetle for what it is
rather than a pest and it's kind of like
a Buddhist idea I guess we we we forget
how to
see you know when we're born we see a
flower in all of its glorious Wonder now
we just walk past them you know it's for
Valentine's Day or something like but
see it for what it is and there's
something really magical about these AIS
just drawn to this glorious creature you
know and kind of fascinated by it and
there's something about that that that
we've lost but the AI has so I thought
that was very interesting it's so
interesting that you brought up the
Buddhist concept I'm Buddhist and we
always hearken back to the lotus flower
and how it's the only flower that
thrives in mud right there you go so
that's all right we on we on the same
wavelength G okay I these chairs are
going to
lift it's elevating me to another going
we're going out I want to talk about the
cinematography cuz it was really
beautiful particularly um the scenes
where we see that really large um wide
shot of the landscape where it's kind of
pinkish and white with little elements
of green here and there and then we get
to see a closeup when hen and Junior are
walking through it is that supposed to
be just straight up mud is it supposed
to be REM of the earth that maybe got
annihilated as something like what was
that represent yeah absolutely um I
guess the Earth is the other character
in the film and um this idea of feeling
the earth dying it's bleeding it's it's
it's been
abused and and reused and abused and it
it's kind of it's hurting it's like a a
a whale that's been beached you know and
it's starting to rot you know it's um
but also you know they do talk about how
how dying can be beautiful so it's
almost like you're kind of drawn by the
images you're drawn by the beauty of the
landscape but at the same time it's
dying so it's almost that idea that
we're blind to our death in a way like
where we're heading with the environment
we all know it's we're being told it's
there but we're just I don't know we
just got a blind eye to it um we shot
that in um in South
Australia um yeah so salinity industrial
runoff probably was what we were
thinking about with the pink it was
really beautiful it was also in terms of
a grounded sci-fi that was our that was
like going to the other planet in a way
so the the Earth became our other planet
so when we think of FO after this
audience has watched it and myself I've
seen it a few times I look at it and I
think it's part psychological Thriller I
think it's a little bit of horror here
and there I think it's um a drama I
think it's a love story I think it's so
many things with you coming out on the
other side of it how do you view it at
this point uh look I totally for me it's
totally hen's
story and I guess what hen fights for is
what the movie is looking into and I
think hen is someone that appreciates
the preciousness of our life how little
time we have left and how we're just
we're just asleep at the wheel and she
doesn't want to be asleep anymore so I
guess the film is just I guess raising
questions around we're not making
judgments necessarily we're just making
question questions around okay life is
real there's stuff on the horizon are we
being kind to each other are we living
the life we want to live and and I guess
that that's what hen is trying to bring
through all those other elements uh is
the roller coaster we sit in to go on it
but but but the through line of the
story is definitely that for me I want
to ask you about the note that hen
leaves where she says when in the
interview with Terence she says that you
know if what he asked her what she would
do and she said I would just leave a
note a blank note because it says
everything and nothing at
all I want to know your thoughts on that
because that's such a huge statement in
a life that she has where she's going
she's going through a roller coaster of
emotions she's in two different
relationships really she's in a
relationship with one Junior and another
Junior one is is a little cold and a
little distant and the other one is very
very affectionate and she's dealing with
all of that so for for her to get to a
place where she just wants to leave a
blank piece of paper says a lot but says
nothing at
all yeah I think that she said
everything she had to say you know she
she said everything at the dinner table
and he said everything he had to say too
like there's nothing out there for you I
mean there's nothing cruel that you
could say to someone like that um and I
guess the blank note is
um that's the only way he's going to
understand it's not what she's going to
say to him I guess so it's you know uh
it's a very powerful way to leave I
think and um and you can see you can see
on the screen him trying to understand
what that means and he doesn't even know
that it was over in the rain he doesn't
even he hadn't even he it didn't even
register um and I guess this is the
whole point of the blank note is him to
actually he's got to work it out for
himself well I saved that for the end
because this film is the kind of film
that it can say everything or it can say
nothing at all it all depends on your
interpretation of it exactly right
depends who's watching it and how you're
watching it absolutely if you're
spiritually closed forget it probably go
and see something else um but if
you if this resonates with you then
it'll it'll take over you for sure
absolutely absolutely well gu Davis I'd
like to thank you on behalf of film
independent for doing this Q&A around
your film Fox it was fantabulous it was
very thought-provoking very deep on so
many different levels and I thoroughly
enjoyed it as I'm sure the audience that
stayed for the Q&A did too so everyone
if we could please just give him a round
of applause thank you so much thank you
so much for uh watching it appreciate it
and thank you so much I'm Carla rata
your moderator please be safe going home
and thank you for coming thank you so
much you're welcome
[Music]